you
here at Mobile World Congress in
Barcelona we're very excited to be
showing off the full extent of the
digital media experience so the full
digital media offering is available
today in the US music movies books and
applications and then books and movies
are also available in three countries
outside of the US we're working to
expand that international footprint
everything that you buy from android
market is powered by the cloud and what
that means is that it's easily portable
across any of your devices additionally
you can add up to 20,000 songs from your
own music collection to that same cloud
account completely for free we have
millions of ebooks available on Android
Market a great selection of titles for
new releases to old classics also a
terrific reading experience so any book
that you buy in android market is
available to read on your tablet on your
phone on the web if you know you're
going to be in an offline situation a
disconnected situation like taking a
flight you can bring that content down
to your device and cash it locally
google music is a complete end-to-end
music experience that includes the
ability to buy music in android market
and then a very unique feature that
allows you to share the songs that you
bought or the albums you bought two
friends on Google+ who will each receive
a full play of that song or album for
free
you